so we need to have just like a very real and
honest conversation today about the reality
that Donald Trump just always gets his ass
kicked internationally by everyone. And I
don't like it. And I want to know whether
you see it my way and whether this is something
you're concerned about and I'm not talking
about any kind of delusional. My framework
for this is not some hyper nationalist. The
U s needs to always come out quote, winning
at the expense of every other country. I want
us working together with the international
community. I want to solve serious problems
in productive ways as as an alliance of countries.
But what I mean is why is it that Donald Trump
is always the loser in negotiations, often
negotiations. He shouldn't be participating
in always the laughingstock, always the guy
that the adults in the room often aren't even
inviting into the room anymore because his
presence is so pointless and counter-productive.
That's what I want to talk about today. It
is embarrassing that the president can't stop
getting his ass kicked day in and day out.
It's boneheaded stupidity and I'm going to
give you some examples. There's lots of good
ones by the way, in a recent daily Co's piece,
which I recommend you check out by Lauren's
Lewis, which was posted to our subreddit,
Donald Trump, as an example, is now considering
jumping into a $15 billion French bailout
of Iran. If Iran is willing to come back into
the Iran nuclear deal, a beat back in compliance
with the Iran nuclear deal. There are people
so out of touch with reality that they see
this as Donald Trump being the big strong
negotiator, but this is maybe the most ignorantly
myopic view of international relations and
specifically of the Iran deal. Then I can
imagine, remember Donald Trump bailed out
of the Iran nuclear deal even though Iran
had been in compliance ever since the deal
was signed.
It was an international embarrassment for
the United States to just not stick to our
agreements without anyone else having violated.
Then why would we not stick to our side of
the deal? The other countries, including France,
had to try at the [inaudible] to salvage what
was potentially left. And one of the things
that they said was, okay, if the U S is out,
we get that. It's logical that you might try
to start a researching of nuclear technology
and developing it and it could potentially
be used for weapons. Uh, what can we do to
keep you in compliance? And of the things
they came up with was a $15 French, a $15
billion French bailout, which now Donald Trump
has Cuntis considering participating in because
he wants Iran to be compliant with the nuclear
deal. This is only a conversation. This is
only on the table because Trump bailed on
the nuke deal to begin with for no reason
whatsoever.
Just getting his ass kicked, getting it kicked
internationally. Another obvious example is
North Korea. We're going to talk more about
North Korea later on in today's program. Trump
is so desperate to be liked and so overconfident
in his negotiating skills that he doesn't
even realize that there's this long history
of North Korean leaders manipulating the United
States or trying to manipulate the United
States and Trump goes and meets with Kim Jong
own no preconditions prenup, plenty of pompous
bluster comes out thinking that he negotiated
some incredible deal that no one else has
been able to do, even though it was the same
promises that the Kim family has been making
for decades. Claims Victory, and then of course
nothing happens, and meanwhile, North Korea
nuclear and weapons development just keeps
going on. Ballistics missiles, missile tests,
Trump getting his ass kicked internationally
again. One more example, I think you're getting
the sort of gist of it.
The Chinese trade war, Trump thinks, I'll
throw some tariffs at China, they'll buckle
down. The U s will win. However, he defines
that, nevermind that he doesn't even understand
how tariffs work. He doesn't understand how
the U S China relationship works and China
instead says, okay, you're putting tariffs
on us. We'll put tariffs on you. We'll get
our aluminum and our steel elsewhere. We'll
make a deal with Russia for energy development
and exploration. We'll get our soil elsewhere
and Trump gets his ass kicked. Again, crushing
farmers, crushing related industries. And
the world is just wondering, what is this
guy doing? Why is he doing this? Could we
maybe not have a president getting his ass
kicked weekly? And I've been very careful
when I make a comparison between Trump and
George W. Bush. I don't want to do it in any
way that suggest George W. Bush was anything
other than a neo-conservative maniac with
terrible policies.
Bush didn't get his ass kicked in this way
internationally, weekend and week out. Bush
made terrible policy decisions. I disagreed
with his moral framework, uh, based on, uh,
a born again, Christianity or whatever it
was that he most recently ascribed to. Uh,
he was a warmonger economically. I didn't
agree with the guy, but he wasn't getting
his ass kicked in the boneheaded way that
Donald Trump is weekend and week out. Our
historical allies are looking around wondering
what's wrong with this guy? It's not just
that they disagree with the decisions or the
underlying policy. To the extent Trump has
an underlying political philosophy, they just
can't understand why he keeps doing the most
boneheaded things to his own disadvantage.
And it's reflecting extremely poorly on the
United States. The world, you know, uh, the,
the trunk may have, uh, high approval among
red state Republicans, 55 plus.
I'm sure among that group, his approval rating
is off the chart. But the world is wondering
how could Americans be so dumb and this is
the way they're thinking about us now. How
could they be so dumb as to have voted this
guy in, in the first place? We need to change
that in November of next year. And I hope
that we will.